So for the twelfth day of Christmas we thought we'd have an unboxing.
So, the video's not about the cardboard, though the chemistry of cardboard is quite interesting,
but let's see what's inside.
We have another present from our fan, Negayesu Nawa, in Japan.
It's the fourth version of his periodic table clock
and you can see it has a really beautiful spiral going round and round
with all the elements including flerovium [and] livermorium. Really up to date.
It's a periodic table clock which will join all the other periodic table clocks in my office
Brady: How many have you got in there?
I've already got four.
Here what we have is a really nice demonstration of the periodic table
and we also have something that summarizes one person's passion for the periodic table.
Our fan's passion, and it's a passion that all of us making PeriodicVideos and those that are watching it share.
Chemistry is a fantastic subject.
It's really exciting. Even the most boring things like a burnt piece of wood has chemical secrets inside it
So, for day 12 we have Periodic Table Clock
Sofia's Sodium Tile
Osmium and Thorium
Periodic Table Handkerchief
Charred Beam from our New Lab
A Fan from a Fan
Anthracite from Pennsylvania
Guitar Plectrum that glows
Four Drinking Vessels
Three Chemical Badges
Two Periodic Table Bed Covers
and One Piece of Tartaric Acid from a Swiss Wine Barrel
Thank you for watching our 12 days of Christmas
Thank you to everyone who sent us these presents
Thank you to everybody who sent us e-mails, sent us pictures, sent us comments
We're looking forward to sharing lots of Chemistry with you in 2016.